[ __ ] start
thank you
morning come to the table there so we
can see you and let us know who we're
working with case worker Lafleur
okay gentlemen what we're going to be
doing this morning is after the two of
you leave the area and back to where
you're going to be I'm going to have
officer Batista I'm going to have you
bring mr. Simpson in and we will go from
there the camera angle that you've got
is perfect if you'll keep your camera
right there that'll allow us to see the
people we're supposed to be seen and
caseworker Lafleur I will refer to you
if you'll have your program up in your
computer system up there are some
questions I'm going to be asking you to
confirm for us so if you'll be ready to
do that I would appreciate that so
gentlemen if you'll if you'll go to your
spots for me and bring mr. Simpson and I
believe he has representation with him
if he'll bring them to the table I'd
appreciate it thank you
[Music]
more space for me
[Music]
[Applause]
Gregg and mr. Swenson will you please
give me your ndse number for the record
102 7 8 too old thank you good morning
mr. Simpson and you're represented by
whom this morning mr. Malcolm Laverne my
attorney attorney ok and welcome mr.
Laverne mr. Simpson the first thing I'm
going to do is put on the record your
notice of this hearing and advisement of
rights and ask you if you will recognize
your signature for me please yes I
believe yes okay thank you having
recognized your signature I'll declare
for the record that you've been properly
noticed in will go forward I'm chairman
Bisbee with me this morning to the right
is commissioner and all to my left is
confirm Jackson and then to her left is
Commissioner kurta we're seeing you the
smaller on an aggregated case sentence
and that is cases number C 2 3 7 8 9 o
count 9 assault with a deadly weapon C 2
3 7 8 9 o count 6 use of deadly weapon
enhancement C 2 3 7 8 9 o count an
assault with a deadly weapon C 2 3 7 8 9
o count 5 use of a deadly weapon
enhancement C 2 3 7 8 9 o count 8 use of
a deadly weapon enhancement C 2 3 7 8 9
o count 7 use of a deadly weapon
enhancement and one of the things I want
you to make to make you aware those
enhancements include both to the
kidnapping and the robbery charges even
though they're not necessarily the way
I've said it make that clear and a
caseworker look more
I have a parole eligibility date of
October 1 2017 with a current expiration
date of September 29 2022 is that
correct have a pro eligibility Naida of
October 1st 2017 floor is there anything
that would change that parole
eligibility date that pro eligibility
date is not going to change okay thank
you very much mr. Simpson you are
getting the same hearing that everyone
else gets I want to make that clear from
the from the get-go however since we
have a trout of people here that have
not taken advantage of our public
meetings before in order to attend a
hearing some of the things I'm going to
say are going to get a light little bit
lengthy so you will understand
everything but it will be due
information for some other folks so just
wanted to let you know that from the
get-go so I will tell you that as
appointed members of the Nevada Board of
parole commissioners we have an ethical
duty to consider each inmate for parole
in a fair and consistent manner like
other parole boards across the country
our responsibilities include needing to
balance prisoner rehabilitation with
Public Safety as well as taking action
that considers the interests of justice
so that's what we're doing here this
morning we have adopted a guideline to
assist us in making consistent decisions
we apply the elements and factors of our
guideline to each inmate being
considered for parole a component of the
guideline is our risk assessment the
board uses a scientifically developed
validated risk assessment as part of its
parole guideline the risk assessment
helps us determine which inmates are
more or less likely to return to prison
if we release them on parole
using a risk assessment is not unique to
Nevada as a number of other state parole
boards also use them we have revalidated
our assessment three separate times in
the past 14 years and has consist
gently shown to be predictive using this
risk assessment has significantly
improved our overall performance I'm
going to go over each of those items
with their of the risk assessment with
you at this time and just as an aside on
this risk assessment is being
revalidated even as we speak by the jfa
Institute so it's pretty darn predictive
is the bottom bottom line here so my
first question for you mr. Simpson were
you arrested for the first time at the
age of 24 or older I was arrested
arrested for the first time I think of
at age of 46 or 47 the age of 24 yes yes
okay and I am I correct that you have
never been on parole or probation before
therefore you have never had a parole or
probation revocation that is correct
okay and I have that you are were
unemployed at the time of this offense
because you were in retirement status
that's correct yes okay now this is a
property and conviction it we're
currently hearing you on the robberies
and the enhancements and so you have
been assessed as a property offender now
we've also assessed you as having a
substance abuse problem I'll tell you
why that is you have indicated also in
the past that alcohol had a big factor
in this particular crime and the fact
that you have spent the last almost nine
years in prison because of an
alcohol-related incident would be
indicative of having some sort of a at
least temporary substance abuse problem
so we have scored you with having some
history there we have you as male
and we have that you are currently well
very recently turns 90 years old 90 I'm
sorry about that we don't have you is
having any gang affiliation nor has the
nbocc found you to have any gang
involvement we do note that you have
completed one of the vocational
trainings in having completed the
computer application course we note that
you have not had any disciplinary 's
either current or pending and there
you're currently medium level they're at
Lovelock correctional center would you
say that all of those items are correct
sir yes ma'am okay you do score out the
risk score scores you in a low a low
risk however because of your particular
offense that severity is the highest
when we combine your risk score along
with your offense severity our guideline
recommendations are that we consider
factors now what consider factors means
as we consider everything in terms of
whether or not you're a risk to
reoffended return to our criminal
justice system and so what we do at this
point when we're looking at the risk
score we also look like at what are
called aggravating and mitigating
factors
now aggravating and mitigating factors
don't include everything in the world
they're very specific as to what we
consider under under those items also so
under the aggravating and mitigating
factors in your particular case we have
mitigating or positive things for
considering you for parole is the fact
that you've been disciplinary free
throughout your entire period of
incarceration you don't have any prior
conviction history you have community
and family support you have what appears
to be stable release plans you have
participated in programming some rather
significant programming on the
aggravating factors and the only thing
that fits under our aggravating cat
characteristics in terms of risk in your
city
is that at the time of this offense your
victims indicated that they were in fear
for their safety
having been threatened with a gun during
the commission of a crime so those are
the risk aggravating mitigating things
we are considering that's your overall
risk score right now I'm going to stop
talking for a while and ask the members
of the panel if they might have any
questions of you yeah mr. Simpson you've
lived most of your life in the public
spotlight yet you go into a hotel room
in Las Vegas
bring along four other men with you two
of them are armed and robbed the two
victims of property what were you
thinking
well
I'm this might be a long I don't I'll
try to be honest with it I have been
contacted by men named Rishi oh he had
contacted me over a period of time told
me that there was some guys that was
trying to get him to fence my property
and he thought I should come and get it
well I've kind of blew him off because
I'm really not interested in football
property I don't collect memorabilia
only my own personal items
he was pretty persistent in calling me
and finally I told him well see if you
get pictures of what they have he sent
me some pictures and what I saw was my
family my mother's albums pictures of my
kids growing up certificates of
accomplishments of mine pictures of what
I call significant famous people letters
of myself so I told him I would really
like to get this stuff so after after a
peer at a time through what he described
in court as as the perfect storm we all
ended up in Las Vegas you know I was
there for a wedding and he told me that
the property was there and what I like
to try to get the property that's of
course I would like to get the property
he told me the names of what he thought
were the people in the room and I
realized these are friends of mine
you know actually guys who helped me
move help me move and store some of this
stuff right so on the day of this
incident he came to my hotel to talk
about how this would take place I told
him I met with a lawyer last night and
my sister and my daughter and some other
friends and discussed it I pointed out
another lawyer that was at the pool
slide as a part of this wedding party
that was going on I said I discussed
with him and they told me that I can't
do this if
we're going to their home even to their
storage oj you cannot go in there
because if they asked you to leave you
got to leave i say Risha you got to get
him to bring it to a public place he
said well let me see what I can do all
of this has been testified to so I'm not
just going yeah he called me a totally
he told him to bring it to his room and
he's gonna have it brought to his hotel
and would I come and get it I said of
course I'll come and get it he says a
lot of stuff well Jane you better bring
some friends well I couldn't I had a
couple of friends there at the wedding
that was gonna go with me he also said
you should bring security I said well I
know these guys I don't think I need any
security I mean it turns out that one of
the guys Bruce here I didn't know it was
him I thought it was another guy named
Mike a friend of here's an ex-partner of
his but I said I don't need any security
well later that day when they arrived at
his hotel and spreaded out my my
property he called and he said are there
here you come here I'll meet you in the
lobby and you need security Oh Jay this
guy fiercely big guy and the Moodle yeah
he's a little weird I still told him
this guy's not dangerous man but he says
man brings some security during the day
when he was there he met people from the
wedding and one guy McClinton said he
did security in Las Vegas and it would
help his business if he could have me as
a client I told him I didn't need him
but after he insisted that I bring
security I said I can use your help I
went through the hotel I met mr. ratio
in the lobby the two guys they also met
us there which was a big mistake
obviously
that white soon after this and mr. Ricci
Oh lettuce took his room put the key in
the door and let us in I know I've seen
the last two or three days the media
reporting me broke in the room what we
did break in any room mr. Vishal paratus
in the devil when I came into the room I
noticed spread out everywhere was my
personal property you know the only
thing I saw that was on display that
wasn't mine with some baseballs and I
made it clear to everybody those are not
mine all I want is my property and I
think there's a tape of it you hear me
only at least three or four occasions
that I just want my property go forward
and try to make it a little quicker at
some point we started when we're leaving
the room actually I was being pushed out
of the room by the security guys because
while I was in there and I recognized
Bruce was there I was surprised to see
him as he testified that was shocked
ability to see him Bruce has been a
friend of mine he's traveled with me
we've done a lot of business together
over the years and he and I said man
what are you doing here you know he
explained to me why he was at NYU yet my
property there and I told him but Jesus
told me I accepted I understood why you
know it was owned 607 people were losing
their homes a guy over there money
couldn't pay him the money gave me my
property to sell I told him I understood
that but you still should have told me
we had a chance to talk about this at a
later date and I apologized I accepted
his apology
I apologized for these two guys that got
pointed a gun at it
he's travel with me he's known me when
I've had security he's known me when a
venue has supplied security and there
are times even at that security for me
he knows I would never ever direct
anybody the 40
daddy more even threatening I've never
done this in my life I want to point out
you mentioned all those gun charges
Bruce and Alfred they made it clear
during the trial that I had no weapon
they didn't feel threatened by me and I
from what you said and that I didn't
threaten it was the other two security
guys that did that I'm not
I haven't made any excuses in the nine
years that I've been here and I'm not
trying to make an excuse now they were
there because of me you know but in no
way shape or form that I wish him any
harm as I was leaving the room and this
was on the tape - Bruce said okay hey
man there's a box that's with that stuff
there Montana prints those don't belong
to you
those are mine man he told me that
because he recognized everything else
that I took out of that room was mine
you know and he also recognized that I
wasn't there to steal that stuff and he
knew I would be as in which I attempted
to even at the desk we didn't know at
the time that this security guy Walter
Alexander and stole his Blackberry you
know form them the minute I saw that I
made him send it back and he gave some
cockamamie story and in the trial that
why he didn't take it back in any event
I'm no danger pulled a gun on me anybody
yeah I never have in my life I've never
been accused of it in my life
nobody has ever accused me of pulling
any weapon on them and Bruce Bruce knows
that I would never do that I never had
I would also as a postscript add that
you know when I got to Lovelock the
state of California took up the issue of
whose property it was they did an
investigation and they came to the
conclusion that it was my topic they
turned it over to me I have it now you
know so I mean it's it's kind of
mind-boggling that
they turned over to me property that I'm
in jail for for trying to retrieve from
anybody and I would never ever ever pull
a weapon on so you believe that the
property was yours it's been ruled
legally by the state of California that
it was my property and they've given it
to me
I have why you went into the property
was yours yes you know I whenever he was
just telling me when Alicia was calling
me just telling me this I wasn't
interested it wasn't until he got actual
pictures of what they supposedly had and
because it was family photos and stuff
that's when I got interested in going
there and I only went there to retrieve
my own property what were you thinking
when the guns were being brandished well
I didn't see the guns brightness I
didn't see you say guns as I understand
it one guy who's behind me somewhere
pointing the gun at him so I never saw
him writing this a gun when I left there
I called back to the room to ask Bruce
you said that there was some pictures
what do you have and I asked him did
this Walt Alexander return his cell
phone he told me no and he says Oh Jay
wasn't cool that got pointed a gun at me
I said who pointed the gun at you says
that kind of described who it was I
think the me honest I didn't really
believe him at the time I asked the
three guys I was with they all said they
didn't see him do it I got back to my
hotel we waited for these two security
guys to show up and the minute they
drove up the first thing I said man that
you pull a gun in that room and he swore
to high heaven he didn't and I asked
Walter Alexander for the cell phone and
he kind of threw the cell phone to me
but well I wasn't aware until until I
was in the car driving back to our hotel
that this guy had actually pointed a gun
at me now earlier in the day when he had
when he was talking to me trying to get
me to let him come out and I and he said
it was for free and all of that he did
show me I didn't know this guy you know
I knew the Alexander guy but I didn't
know this guy
she showed me his license he showed me
his CCR you know I've assumed that
statement gives the guy CC art stuff
they vetted him I should have vetted him
I didn't really need him I knew these
guys weren't dangerous well no you saw
the offenses differ a little bit about
the official records mr. Simpson but
forward here considering the fact that
what we have on record
well brandish you were there property
was taken well I was there I mean so
nice our next question is for you is
what do you think was the impact on your
victims well I know what the impact was
I mean we've talked about it
I mean mr. virtually we had long talks
back then he he told me that he had
tried to call my lawyer they testified
in court that he had called my lawyers
and tried to tell them in the months
previous that guys had my property and
they were trying to sell him but my
lawyer never called him back
he actually testified for me I'm sure
you know doing the trial Bruce and I
talked and Bruce was traumatized by it
fortunately as I said we talked it out
he knew that I would have never condoned
what happened he accepted my apology and
I told him that these guys should be put
in jail if they did that you know I
wasn't gonna defend
unfortunately they got a
get-out-of-jail-free card when they say
Oh J told me nothing I could do about
that but uh I want to point out that you
know Bruce I knew his family I mean when
his mother was terminally ill I caught
her she's a fan I'd call her and sing to
her the night before or the night of my
the jury's verdict his son actually
called me and tried to give me a head up
on something to do with memorabilia and
told me that he and his mother was
cheering for me you know these this
family knows that I wouldn't wish any
harm on these guys ever friends of mine
and I'd like to think we're friends
again thank you good morning mr. Simpson
I conducted your last hearing in 2000 in
2013 with hearing representative mr.
Robin baitz recall that hearing yes all
right at the time we asked you what your
plan would be if we were to grant you to
your consecutive sentence and you told
us that you were going to complete
commitment to change have you done that
no I haven't at one point I couldn't
take the course you know I took I took
two courses that I guess you guys don't
get much credit to it's called
alternative to violence I think it's the
most important course anybody in this
prison can take because it teaches you
how to deal with conflict through
conversation I've been asked many many
times here to mediate conflicts between
individuals and groups and it gave me so
many tools how to use it to you know try
to walk these guys through you know not
throwing punches at one another also at
one point a couple of guys came to me
and they said Oh Jay I understand you're
a Baptist
we're Baptists and we have no Baptist
service here can you help us get a
Baptist service here I worked with them
we now have an ongoing Baptist service
that is well attended I attended of
religiously and pani as intended and I
realized in my nine years here that I
was a good guy on the street I'm sure
when Bruce Acuna you tell you I was
always a good guy but I could have been
a better Christian and my commitment to
changing these could be a better person
alright thank you well we do know that
you have programs over your term of
incarceration now you have completed
victim empathy alternative to violence
both basic and advanced and computer
application I'd like you to tell us a
little bit more about victim empathy and
alternative to violence and how it will
benefit you in the future
the alternative to violence courses I've
always thought I've been pretty good
with people and I basically had spent a
conflict free life you know I I'm not a
guy that ever got into fights on the
street and with the public and everybody
but as that said they give you a bunch
of little tools about how to talk to
people instead of fight instead of
throwing punches tools that I've used
here that you know it's how you talk to
people tone that you use the victim
empathy was once again I I didn't really
see that in this case I didn't really
see that Alfred Beardsley was that was
really affected by it all but Bruce was
affected you know this was uh I saw that
he was affected and as I said I would
have done anything anything not to have
that happened for know if for no other
reason I regret this because he had to
have this got pointed gun at him and he
told me he said man that guy put a gun
in my face you know and I said I didn't
as I said in the beginning I didn't
believe it but I know it to be a to be a
fact now
you know in that that empathy course it
it pretty much tells the guys who's all
there usually they have you talk to your
victim and and what would you say to
them you know if you weren't seeing now
and for you to take you no
responsibility for what you did and to
recognize how it affected their lives as
I said Bruce expressed to me how it
affected him and I as I told him I
couldn't be more apologetic for going to
for him going to them thank you I know
that alcohol was a factor in the instant
offense and have you addressed this
issue as you stated you would well you
know it's I think I made it clear back
then I've never had an alcohol problem
and if I took that alcohol of course it
would have been more you know in for my
children in the case they ended up
having a problem well my kids don't have
a problem I don't think anybody's ever
accused me of having an alcohol problem
with any kind of substance problem of
course on that day I had drinks on that
day but it was a wedding celebration but
I've never had a substance problem at
all so I did okay well you told us in
our last hearing that you were going to
attend a a and that's the reason for my
question was a factor in the instruments
hadn't you been drinking that day
yes yes as I said if we were celebrating
a wedding thing I felt that the
alternative to violence courts and my
involvement with the church I also has
recently became the Commissioner of the
softball league 18 team league my my
primary my primary responsibility was
gruel's enforcement and you know player
deportment you know guys is hot the guys
play they argue my job is that they get
surly with one another to remove them
from the game and if it goes beyond that
to go to coach Fraley and have him
suspended I've never got any blowback
from the guys because they know that I
I've done the best that I can and I'm
just trying to keep them on out of
trouble so my my genuine was false you
know here I've been active totally
active and all the years I've been here
I don't have much time to sit around and
do anything I don't know if Ted had such
a question
so of all of the programs that you've
had an opportunity to complete what do
you believe is the most significant for
you personally well for me personally it
was alternative due to violence as I
said I think that should be mandatory
for every inmate here you know once
again guys get hot here and you know
we've had our share fights here and and
as I said I've been called in some times
to try to keep guys from fighting and
you have groups you know it's the
Surenos are fighting the north town boys
they all it's crazy and most of the time
it's over something really really stupid
you know in a basketball game somebody
has say something to somebody or
somebody or go to somebody to complain
to him about it
and it's how they complain to him about
it that actually initiated the the
conflict you know the fights so I for
the life of me III I don't understand
why that is not mandatory course for
everybody here excuse me my mind is
trying to think of
but that that's that's the course that I
would recommend to everybody I mean I
took her
I took a computer course here not
because I I was a computer illiterate
but I took the computer course because I
sometimes I could never get my kids on
the phone but if you text them or said
something to them on computer you can
get them so I actually took that course
so I could better communicate with my
children prepared you to return to the
community setting you know I spent 12
years leading up to this incident in
Vegas raising two kids and in in in LA I
mean I'm sorry in Miami and you know
with all the media stuff you know we got
these guys like Jeffrey Felix make it up
stories and stuff that was happening out
on the street also but I was able to
keep them to keep the eye on the ball if
you have great grades and went to the
College of their choice and I ended up
missing their graduation because of it
trust me I wish it would have never
happened but as I said the courses that
I taken it I hope it helps me more if I
run into those conflicts with my kids
I'm not a god to ask conflicts on the
street I don't expect to have anyone I
get that when I leave here but I feel
that I'm much better prepared but more
so from I think my my commitment to
being a better Christian because I
thought I was a good guy I had some
problems with fidelity in my life but
I've always been a guy that pretty much
got along with everybody
are you humbled by this incarceration as
I said I wish it would have never
happened I was gonna start and know how
we were gonna do this by apologizing to
the people of Nevada because I wish this
would have never happened I apologize to
him at my sentencing you know there's
nothing I can do about this kind of
media circus is going on right now but I
could do something about the whole thing
in the beginning if I would have made a
better judgement back then none of this
would have happened and I take full
responsibility because I should have
never you know I haven't made any
excuses in nine years here but I should
have never allowed these alleged
security guys to help me because it
turned out they were only trying to help
themselves if they weren't there Bruce
and I we tried to do this we tried to
sit down in the room and call this guy
Mike Gilbert and discuss it all but
these guys took over and we were unable
to do that if we were able to do that
you would have never heard about this
none of us would be here today and
lastly I'd like you to know that we
received hundreds of letters of support
and opposition and while we always
encourage public input the majority of
the opposition letters are asking us to
consider your 1995 acquittal and the
subsequent civil judgment however these
items will not be considered in this
case thank you
I uh when we granted offenders parole
one of the conditions of parole we will
impose is to pay court-ordered
restitution to victims of the crime
according to the judge what a conviction
in this case you were you and your
co-defendants were ordered to pay three
thousand five hundred and sixty dollars
in restitution and return twelve Montana
lithographs to the victims can you tell
us the status of the restitution and the
return of the property taken during the
robbery I was unaware of the restitution
I do know about the the prints when I
was talking to Bruce on the phone and
asking him was there anything else that
should be yours he said a cell phone
right so I said you want to come and
meet us with that I do how do you want
to do it Mr Cashman now the guy didn't
know mr. cash Moore said hey I got to go
by that hotel I'll drop it off right I
you testified to this to this is not an
allegation for me mr. cash more
testified to it so I say this guy is
gonna come back he's gonna drop it off
at the hotel his testimony later ones
that he didn't remember the name of who
he was supposed to drop it off to and
that they had decided to screw oj we're
going to keep this stuff I mean this is
his testimony in court the last thing I
heard is that he actually tried to use
those prints as
you know the word I can't find the word
to get his bet for what his bail
bondsmen he was trying to use it as so
the last that I know of these looked the
grass was that this Cashmore haddem i
didn't know this guy that he Adam and he
testified to the fact in court the
restitution has been paid and there is
no pending yes the property has been
returned to the lithographs as well
Brutus thinking with me that they have
been returned to him all right if
granted parole as opposed to completing
your sentence in prison you will be
under supervision in the community why
is it better to be in community many in
the prison
you know I do have four kids I've missed
a lot of time with those kids I think
I'm a guy who has always been a giving
guy I've even on the street people have
always come to me you saw my reputation
has always been that I'm open to the
public I'm open to everybody
you know I've you know I right now I'm
at a point in my life where all I want
to do is spend time with my as much time
as I can with my children and my friends
and and I'm not looking to be involved
with the media I've had so many offers
for interviews when I've been here and
in Lovelock and I've turned them all
down I'm not interested in it in any of
that I've done my time you know I've
done it as well and it's respectfully
it's I think anybody can I think if you
talk to them warns them they'll tell you
I've been I I gave him my word I believe
in the jury system I've honored their
verdict
I have not complained for nine years all
I've done is try to be helpful and
encourage the guys around there hey man
do your time fight in court and don't do
anything that's gonna extend your time
and that's the life I've tried to live
because I want to get back to my family
do you realize that if you're granted
parole
you could be returned to prison for any
violation or conditions of parole do you
understand that yes sir all right
conditions could be easily as not
drinking alcohol to excess associating
with ex felons leaving the state without
permission being subject to search and
seizure so there's all there's gonna be
a whole slew of conditions you're gonna
have to follow and you think you can be
successful where the terms of parole
I've been ranking nine years I haven't
missed it you know most of my life I
could be stopped and searched whenever
they you know I'm not a guy who lived a
criminal life you know I'm a pretty
straight shooter I've always tried to be
a good soldier and I had no problem none
whatsoever
and living with those conditions the
other side of that as an easily
recognized person in the community if
you're granted parole how will you
handle public scrutiny in the in the
community well I've been wrecking the
high surface since I was 19 years old we
were there it's always a crowd this is
not new to me
rarely have I even even in the last 20
years rarely have I even had any person
give me any negative stuff in the street
other people give you looks and
everything but I'm pretty easily
approachable I dealt with it my whole
life and I really don't foresee any
problem dealing with the public now at
all okay and mister simply we've been
since we've been made aware that you're
requesting to live in Florida I've asked
them captain Shawna Ruby to come to
today's hearing and explain the
pre-release in interstate contract
process for us captain aready is an
officer with the nevada division of
parole on probation he's also the
interstate compact commissioner for the
state of nevada saw him and asked him to
come forward and again these are things
that would happen behind the scenes with
any hearing that we would have but
because we have a crowd of people that
are asking questions we thought it'd be
best to have them captain or Rudy
present to explain it to everyone from
the Department of Public Safety Division
of Conservation as chairman Bisbee
shared with you I serve two roles on
that cap I'm a captain with the division
of probation for headquarters and I also
serve as the Commissioner for the unit
for Nevada for the interstate compact
when it comes to the interstate compact
the things that are looked at is what is
your what is your support system in that
other state the are you a resident of
the other state is defined by the
compact meaning that you were living
there for at least a year entire to the
date you committed the offense or do you
have resident family there that can
serve as your support system and
resident families is fairly specific
but adults siblings and adult children
can serve as your resident family
sponsor to provide you with got tied to
the other state that would allow you to
qualify for a transfer but that's just
the first part of it first we have to
establish what your sport system is and
whether or not you qualify for that
transfer and then we make the
determination if it's in your best
interest to to request that transfer for
you once we make that decision there's a
there's a an offender application for
transfer which includes a waiver of
extradition which is required to be
signed before anyone is allowed to
submit a request for transfer to another
state what that does is it outlines to
you what the requirements of the compact
are that you're subject to terms and
conditions not only by the sending state
which in this case would be Nevada but
also by the receiving state if you were
looking to join your family in Florida
that that the Florida would be able to
impose conditions on you that would be
consistent in the same manner that they
would treat one of their own offenders
in the like circumstance from the once
one set offender application for
transfer with the waiver of extradition
and waiver of extradition serves the
purpose that if for some reason you
violate the terms and conditions of your
supervision
you understand that Nevada has the
authority to come and return you to
Nevada to answer for those violations
once once we obtain that signed defender
application we said we will process that
along with the other paperwork and
documents that we need to submit to the
other state and they will then have up
to 45 days to conduct their
investigation on whether or not whether
or not you qualify for the transfer and
whether or not you have a valid plan of
supervision once they determine that
their caseworkers will forward that
through their compact office back to the
Nevada compact office and once we have a
decision by that other state then that
would be provided to you through the new
year case manager
at the Department of Corrections that's
how the interstate compact part works on
the pre-release side the pre-release we
have pre-release specialists who work
closely with the caseworkers at the
Nevada Department of Corrections and
they develop they help to develop a bit
that valid plan of supervision we were
talking about what is your plan of
release where do you want to go to whose
your support system once they make that
determination they process the they
process the information that's necessary
and in this case if you were to apply
for an interstate compact our
pre-release specialist would be the ones
to Ford those documents to the other
state for their consideration once the
determination was made and once a valid
plan was developed then they would work
with your caseworker to set up your
release and your caseworker would then
manage the release through the Nevada
Department of Corrections
thank you thank you thank you
um now mr. Laverne I'm gonna defer to
the two of you and mr. Simpson we'd like
mr. Simpson to be able to tell us
anything else he'd like to tell us we'd
also like to hear from one of the
supporters if one of them wishes to make
a brief statement to the board and we
would also like to hear your statement
mr. Laverne so I'm gonna put that back
to you as to what order you want those
three things to happen mr. we're gonna
hear from mr. Simpson's daughter
Arnel Simpson first and then I'll make
some closing remarks Hey and officer
Batista if you will make that switch for
us please thank you
good one you will give us your name and
for the record in your relationship to
mr. Simpson all right now Simpson
my dad told his child before feel free
to speak a little nervous so bear with
me I know it's a lot
as you know I'm here on behalf of my
family for the purpose of expressing
what we believe is the true character of
my father
no one really knows how much we have
been through this ordeal in the last
nine years excuse me
my experience with salmon is is that
he's like my best friend in my rock
and as a family we recognize that he is
not the perfect man but he's clearly a
man and the father has done his best to
behave in a way that speaks to his
overall nature and character which is
always to be positive no matter what he
has spent the last nine years of
Lovelock as we all know and has been a
perfect inmate following all the rules
and making the best of the situation
just truly amazing to me under the
circumstances the choice that he made
nine years ago that resulted in the
sentencing counterproductive to what he
was trying to achieve we're all wedding
of a very good friend as his daughter I
cannot my dad recognizes that he took
the wrong approach could not handle the
situation he could have handled the
situation differently my sibling and
family know
that he didn't make the right decision
on that day but we know that his
intentions were not to go in and to just
make the wrong decision at the wrong
time throughout this ordeal we have
remained close we have stayed strong and
I for myself I'm grateful to God for
giving us the strength to get through
this last nine years and to stay
positive always no matter what and a lot
of that is because of him so on behalf
of my family my brother my sister and
aunt uncle his friends we just want him
to come home we really do we want him to
come home and I know in my heart that
he's very humbled throughout the
situation
this has been hard be honest this has
been really truly hard and there's no
right or wrong way to explain how to
handle this but we do know that I know
that he is remorseful he truly is
remorseful and when we just want him to
come home so that we can move forward
for us quietly but to move forward so I
thank you for allowing me to be here
this morning
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You commissioner do you have a
copy of a letter I provided through your
liaison
it's an undated letter from mr. Simpson
to Assemblyman Osvaldo fumo that should
have been provided to you yes okay give
me two seconds get set up here because
that's that's where I'm gonna start
did you take the letter I can't find it
now
that's what you
and the letter as you can see is very
short so I think it would be appropriate
just to read it into the record if the
commissioners would allow me to but the
first thing I have to do is find it here
it is the by way of setting this letter
up by the way the most important part
about this letter is that this was not a
letter that mr. Simpson provided to me
okay what happened is mr. Simpson at
some point wanted me to communicate with
an individual by the name of Osvaldo
fumo he's an assemblyman now and prior
to that time and still now he's an
attorney and in the interest of full
disclosure he actually was one of mr.
Simpson's attorneys during the Habeas
proceedings related to this case but
since that time
Osvaldo or osseous I call him he's a
friend of mine too
he became an assemblyman with the nevada
legislature and after that mr. Simpson
sent a mister fumo a letter and mr. and
I found out about that letter not
through mr. Simpson I found out about
this letter through mr. kuhmo
when I was advised to thank him for
Thank You fumo for providing some it was
at books and some educational equipment
to the prison here at Lovelock Nevada
and so here's I'm gonna read that letter
and by the way mr. Simpson did
authenticate this letter this morning
I'd only produce this to him this
morning when I got to see him prior to
this hearing he did indicate that he was
the one who wrote this letter and even
though it's not dated he indicated it
was probably sent to Ozzie within the
last nine months or so so dear
legislator fumo first of all allow me to
say how happy I was to hear about your
new position as a state legislator
although I was not surprised to hear
about your interest in furthering the
education and helping of prison inmates
I must admit I've always taken my
exposure to education for granted partly
due to my prowess as an athlete I have
always been afforded opportunities for
higher education it wasn't until I got
to prison that I realized just how many
people did not have the exposure to said
education
in part because of their circumstances
I eat gangs bad neighborhoods like a
parental supervision poverty etc but
Ozzy I can't tell you how inspiring it
is to see how set inmates have taken
advantage of the educational department
and the advantages that it offers I have
seen a change in some inmates as far as
their self-esteem goes that is amazing
they come to me to talk about subjects
that they would never would have never
even thought about before their exposure
to education they talked to me about
things they want to do when they are
released things they never would have
thought about they were capable of
before they say quote you can't teach an
old dog new tricks end quote and as a
quote old dog end quote my friend I can
tell you that is not true
I am currently taking a computer science
course or just a computer course that
has shown me that even I am capable of
learning new skills these new skills at
the very minimum will help me better
communicate with my children who knows
you may even see a webcast or blog in my
future I work in the athletic department
here at Lovelock and I fully enjoy what
I do and can tell you this that this is
very important for the inmates to have a
release for their energy and for
recreation but I can think of no better
place to use state funds than to educate
add to their self esteem and to prepare
these guys for their eventual release in
closing I want to tell you how much I
look forward to the following -
following your political career and your
participate participation in what I know
will be a very successful prison
educational program gratefully yours
Orrin Thal J Simpson and it's signed by
mr. Simpson and the reason I wanted to
read this to you is because it just kind
of surprised mr. Simpson with it is
because obviously this is mr. Simpson's
what I would consider one of mr.
Simpson's first opportunities to have
clout in the political system of the
state of Nevada he pretty much has an
end at that point
as Ozzy fumo who they had an
attorney-client relationship with a very
good relationship and now Ozzy is in the
assembly he's in a position of power and
what does mr. Simpson do does he say
mozzie can I have a better bed or does
he see say Ozzy can you get me can you
pull some strings get me out of here
earlier no he doesn't do any of that he
uses that clout that one time he has to
some clout in the state of Nevada he
uses that a clout to obtain funding for
books in education in this prison you
know and some of those men is mr.
Simpson said they really are going to
get out and they're going to have a
decent and a better life for themselves
as the result of mr. Simpson's efforts
through mr. Foom oh I think that's the
definition of character and frankly I
think if it was me personally who had
been in prison for nine years and
frankly forget nine years nine days if I
had that opportunity in a position of
someone in a position of power who could
do something for me like this I
obviously get me out of jail okay but he
doesn't do that it is very very very
selfless he's thinking about the people
here and it's also the definition so
when it asked earlier about being
humbled in some humility it also shows a
genuine form of humility that he has the
capabilities to think of people here who
are not as empowered and not as
privileged as he has been and and and
when he gets out probably will continue
to be in society so that's that's the
first part of my closing remarks the
second part of my closing remarks is to
deal with the unday or the other
individual in this case that was a
victim he's not here mr. furlong is
sitting right here and that's mr.
Beardsley mr. Beardsley as you I'm sure
are aware is no longer with us he passed
away in about November of 2015
however mr. Beardsley and mr. furlong
have made calls to my office and I've
spoken to them both at various points
and the last time I recall speaking to
mr. Beardsley was in September of 2011
this is not that long after I maybe been
representing mr. Simpson for a couple of
years
point I was a little uncomfortable that
mr. Beardsley who is a victim in a case
and my client is considered the person
who victimized him was calling me so I
did explain to him that I wanted to
record the conversation and he consented
and I asked him if you wanted an
attorney before he talked to me and said
he's fine I I say this I bring up this
recorded conversation because I reviewed
it in anticipation of this hearing and
that was from 2011 as I as I stated
before and since he's no longer here I
think I could just speak from the dead
for speak for him you know someone who's
speaking from the dead he indicated in
no uncertain terms in that conversation
that he had cleared up this matter with
mr. Simpson he was trying his hardest to
do whatever you want to get mr. Simpson
out of prison and he had just they're
just made right mr. Simpson had
apologized to him and they had just
basically made it right and he was very
very and he had sent letters to mr.
Simpson for mr. Simpson hadn't responded
and that was probably on the advice of
counsel at the time and then also there
was another issue of and mr. Simpson has
raised this issue and I want to
emphasize this again that mr. Beardsley
had a set of photos and these are not
memorabilia mr. Simpson if he didn't
make this point already he could care
less about some signed football or some
signed photos he could care less about
he could rip them up and burn them up I
know they may they mean a lot to a lot
of people but those that that was not
what was really the true impetus for
what happened here what was the true
impetus was is that there were intimate
family photos that were taken from him
literally stolen and there is no dispute
that these would not be any type of
judgment collections these are just
intimate family photos mr. Simpson had a
former family he had a second family
there's pictures of him with his mother
and two other other things famous
celebrities and they were not subject to
being taken they they probably have no
value to most people but they have all
the value in the world mr. Simpson
they're not footballs and that's what
set her off and mr. Beasley had these
photos or he at least represented to me
on the phone that he had these photos
and I had made every effort that I could
to try and obtain
those intimate family photos that I was
well aware were basically all mr.
Simpson won in the first place
unfortunately whatever happened mr.
Beardsley was never able to get those to
me he explained that he had them and I
tried to make every effort to get those
from him and and then at some point
along the line we lost contact and then
I just discovered that he had passed
away but I will speak on mr. berzins
behalf from that phone conversation that
at least as a September of 2011 him and
mr. Simpson had made things right okay
and finally and again obviously the
Commission is not used to hearing where
victims are calling people who are
imprisoned their attorneys and having
multiple conversations with them I've
also had mr. Freeman rooster mom who's
sitting right here to my left and will
testify shortly he's also called my
office he had called before many years
ago and we had spoken I can't
necessarily remember the substance of
those conversations they won't record or
if they were I can't I couldn't find
them in my files but he's recently
called again he called me on July 3rd
and he called me on July 14th and both
times I missed the calls but I I called
him back and I can hear the that mr.
furlong has made things and mr. Simpson
have made things right with each other
that he's accepted mr. Simpson's apology
wholeheartedly he seems to be a
fundamentally really really good guy
who's fallen on some hard times recently
and he told me that he would be calling
in tuck coming in and testifying
favorably for mr. Simpson I made sure I
told him probably 15 or 20 times to say
whatever he wanted to say because you
know obviously mr. Simpson's attorney
talking to a victim it could be
interpreted the wrong way so again mr.
mr. monk say whatever you want to say
nobody's telling you how to testify here
and one of the things we did and I did
inform the parole and probation about
both of those conversations on July 3rd
and July 14th and one of the things that
we did spend a lot of time to I mean
that was a small portion of our
conversations was the
the remorse on mr. Simpson's part that
mr. furlong accepted most of the time we
spent we were talking about some other
unfortunate things that happened with
mr. Fremont I believe not I believe I
know because I've researched this now
there was some civil litigation that
went on out there and this was against
the one of the primarily against one of
the uncharged co-defendants in this case
a guy named individual named Ricci Oh
something happened in this civil
litigation and I don't know what's going
on with it at this point in time other
than mr. furlong addressed those
concerns with me
I told him that I would look into it I
explained to him that he really should
talk to his lawyers who were involved in
that civil litigation to try and make
that that judgment do whatever he wants
it to do
and it was it was unfortunate I believe
that you know this is this kind of is an
opportunity to show you that in the
criminal case he's completely the victim
but he's filed a civil lawsuit and the
jury actually found for long 16 percent
liable for what happened here it was was
pretty it was pretty unique to say the
least
in any event mr. firm was gonna testify
but I did feel that I needed to note
that I don't think I have a point to
prove with mr. Foreman other than he did
represent that he was going to testify
favorably for mr. Simpson and that he
did discuss with me on multiple
occasions this idea of some civil
judgment out there that he was hoping
that mr. Simpson could take care of for
him and that's a thank you very much and
para Danny except that you know I've
come here I've spent nine years making
no excuses about anything I am sorry
that things turned out the way they they
did I had no intent to commit a crime
I came here I tell the inmates all the
time and I don't want to hear about your
crime
you know argue in court here we're all
convicts I'm a convict do your time and
don't do anything that's extend your
time I told the warden when I got here
mr. Lagrange I think it was mr.
carpenter and this vegan that I would be
no problem
I believed in this jury system I will
honor what the jury said and I will be
no problem you know and I think I kept
my word I as I said I've done my time I
just like to get back to my family and
friends and believe it or not I do have
some real friends but I I don't think I
could have represented this prison I
don't think it in an inmate has ever
represented it better than I I did my
time I tried to be helpful to everybody
and as I said Bruce Bruce and uh
Beardslee I made up with them years ago
you know so I'm sorry it happened I'm
sorry the Nevada I wish I wish we sure
we're never called me I thought I was
glad to get my stuff back but it wasn't
worth it
you know nine years away from your
family it's just just not worth it and
and I I'm sorry
thing for the record your exploration is
as of today nine twenty nine twenty two
and for all those people in the world
wonder having that how that adds up to
thirty three years in the state of
Nevada good behavior complying with the
rules can mean up to a 50% reduction off
the back end of your of your sentence if
granted parole that September 29 2022
time could even move closer so I wanted
to put that on the record and at this
point I'll ask them option Bautista if
you will move mister Laverne and mr.
Simpson again and we invite mr. Frohman
to the table please ma'am thank you
thank you and mr. furlong if you will
put your your own name on the record for
us please and then proceed yes it is
Bruce for mom and I'd like to thank thee
thank you for the opportunity to be able
to speak today first and foremost I'd
like to state that I'm not here just as
mr. Simpson's friend of almost 27 years
because that I am but today I'm also
appearing as the victim of the crime of
on September 30th hours September 13th
up to South 2007 on that day I felt that
mr. Simpson was
misguided not by himself that also by
Tom Mauricio he was led to believe that
on that day there were going to be
thousands of pieces of his personal
memorabilia pictures of his wife his
band from his first marriage pitches of
his kids
Arnel and Jason family heirlooms he was
told they were going to be possibly his
wife's wedding ring thousands of things
it was misled about what was going to be
there that day a man named Thomas ratio
had promised him this big this big
package in reality once it Thomas Rees
who had never met me never met me in his
entire life until the night of the
robbery he got there and saw this stuff
he went down he got OJ and instead of
telling him that that's not what was
there he brought him up anyway
when OJ got there unfortunately he was
already worked up and had people with
him that were hollering and screaming
there's a lot of commotion going on in a
very very small room real small room
with OJ and a lot of things happen very
quickly and unfortunately if thought if
oj had it just said everybody out of
here Oh Jay Bruce and I need to talk for
a minute
none of this needed to happen but that
didn't happen
and
it took one things I want to make clear
is that it took me two years in a
California Court because and a judge's
infinite wisdom instead of going ahead
and turning thing I sent to a California
Court to get straightened out and after
having to fight the Goldman's lawyers
OJ's lawyers and it took me two years to
get back with over 600 items a majority
of it did come back to me because I had
to go back 19 years through our
friendship but I had to go back 19 years
and produce records for eight percent of
this stuff and it is true that items in
that room belonged OJ there were no two
what two ways about it but it's also
true that I have never stolen anything
from OJ I did not I have never stolen
from OJ I think OJ will admit that I did
not it wasn't me an ex partner of mine
and his mistress Christy Luca Meier have
taken things other people have taken
things from OJ but I have never stolen
from oj oj is my friend always has been
and I hope will remain my friend but
there were things in that room and I
admit to that and I'm sorry things did
not work out differently but there were
and I will make this clear to you
Oh Jay never held a gun on me
there was a coward in that room man
named McClinton came up gangster-style
act like a big man he held the gun on me
not Oh Jake
another man came in hit me not oj he
never laid a hand on me a lot of people
were yelling bagged that stuff up let's
get things let's get out of here during
the trial he testified against oj and
this is why perhaps I absolutely
believed him after I had already
testified against oj i'd already said
everything I had to say we happened to
pass each other in the hallway and OJ
came up to me and said can I talk to you
for a minute we had a chance to talk to
each other I told him I'm sorry that I
would I did not get the opportunity to
call him and tell him that I had that
those few items that belong to him I
told him I'm sorry that all him because
we'd been apart for a long time we
hadn't had a chance to talk for many
many years and I'd been buying stuff
from Mike guilt and
I wish I had said sorry I am we've got a
same between a city handout I shook his
hand but I forgive you we all make
mistakes he's been here in for an inmate
he's been an example to others during
the trial I recommended that's what I
read I'm here to say that I've known oj
for a long time I don't feel that he's a
threat to anyone out there he's a good
man
I know that he does a lot for other
people and I feel that nine a half 233
years was way too long and I feel that
it's time to give him a second chance
it's time for him to go home to his
family his friends Bruce I'm getting out
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
before we break for deliberation I want
to ask the panel okay what's going to
happen now is deliberation again another
thing we do with every single case but a
little differently today because frankly
we need our offices back folks so we're
hoping to deliberate we'll come to an
agreement and be able to produce an
order sometime in the next 30 minutes or
so so what's going to happen is we are
going to break if and then after
deliberating we'll come back to this
room I'll ask each Commissioner to vote
I'll vote myself if we are able to agree
when those votes are cast that will be a
final decision if it becomes obvious
that there is a split on this particular
panel I have commissioners Eddie gray
and Commissioner Michael Keeler standby
in Las Vegas and they will either we
will call them they will either cast a
vote then or ask for deliberate to
return to deliberation so that is what
we're planning at this moment we are
about to leave the room
I know officer Batista is going to
arrange to clear the courtroom there
also I ask that here that you give us
about two minutes to clear out of the
room so that you're not chasing us down
the hall and then we'll give you a
five-minute notice that our deliberation
is over and that we're ready to cast
votes so on that I will call this this
hearing into recess and we will return
after deliberation
gripping procedure there at a Nevada
parole board where OJ Simpson leaves the
court he's been appearing on video link
before that parole board seeking to
leave the Lovelock Correctional Center
where he's been incarcerated for the
last nine years on parole and we've
heard evidence testimony from OJ Simpson
himself from his lawyer there and indeed
from one of the victims of the crime for
which he was convicted leading to him
being sentenced to 33 years in Lovelock
after that crime in Las Vegas well I'm
joined now by Michael McParland Dirk you
see us eternity attorney in in UK so
Mike at me what did you make of that I
mean and how'd you rate her OJ Simpson's
chances of getting parole damn it was
like watching a car crash everything is
set up to give him parole today
everything that the the chairman said
how the board was constructed the
information they passed out to the
public to explain the whole process is
geared towards giving him parole and
then he started talking then he started
being asked questions and I think the
board took him by surprise because they
didn't do as they done in 2013 an
earlier parole hearing where they
started the process by asking him to
make a little statement because he said
I thought we'd intended that I would
apologize to the state of Nevada and all
this what they did Tha started with the
first commissioner mr. Toney court
Corder the the ball gentleman in the
gray green suit they asked him why such
a person of a public background as he
should do this such a thing and then OJ
started talking and I've been watching
this one after the other they've
accidentally done their best to to lose
him this parole application why so I
mean what they want to hear obviously is
contrition and acceptance acceptance of
the offense now the long introduction
from OJ was really it was all you know
it's all somebody else's fault
it's all I've never made an excuse
but here they all are the same excuse is
being repeated again and again that he
actually ran at the trial the he's then
asked by a masseuse and Jackson the
dark-haired lady about things he'd said
to her in 2013 when they gave a parole
for example about alcohol he'd been
drinking that day and that's a big no-no
within the rehabilitation parole and
he'd promised in that hearing he was
going to go to Alcoholics Anonymous so
she asked him well did you go oh no no I
have never never I don't have a drink
problem on all this you've said in the
in the parole hearing you were going to
go to a certain course about changing a
behavior did you go to that well
eventually no no he went to some other
courses which he thought were important
such as avoiding violence alternatives
of violence but he didn't do this and
all the time you see occasionally this
this strange chameleon that his OJ
Simpson this character who was known to
had America in the sixty 70s 80s as this
this figure the transcended race and
just everyone's hero it could turn into
this
snap he's got a temper inside him just I
just pulls that Michael because I want
it just if people haven't been sitting
all the way through the hearing it's it
was gripping stuff let's just go play a
little bit of OJ Simpson and when he was
asked why he wanted to get parole this
is part of his justification right now
I'm at a point in my life where all I
want to do is spend time with my as much
time as I can with my children and my
friends and and I'm not looking to be
involved with the media I've had so many
offers for interviews when I've been
here and in Lovelock and I've turned
them all down I'm not interested in it
in any of that I've done my time you
know I've done it as well and it's
respectfully it's I think anybody can I
think if you talk to them warns them
they'll tell you I've been I I gave him
my word I believe in the jury system
I've honored their verdict
I have not complained for nine years all
I've done is try to be helpful
and encourage the guys around a man do
your time fight in court and don't do
anything that's gonna extend your time I
want to go live to Nevada where of
course said hearing is taking place
Carson City to be precise in Nevada our
US correspondent Greg Milam is there and
Greg this is probably the most famous
prisoner in the world certainly one of
them huge huge interest yeah you know
even the sports networks here in the US
are showing these proceedings live which
tells you a lot about the level of
interest that there is in this this
phenomenon that is OJ Simpson a man who
divides opinion in America right back to
that what they called the trial of the
century in 1995 when of course he was
cleared of the charges of killing his
former wife Nicole Brown Simpson and her
friend Ron Goldman subsequently of
course found to be responsible by a
civil court for their deaths and ever
since he has been a figure that is
hugely controversial here and in many
people's minds when he was sentenced
back in 2008 for this robbery the the
charges that he's now appearing at a
parole hearing for many people felt that
the state of Nevada in many ways was was
punishing him for what they perceived
had happened in in California and that
murder trial because it was seen as a
harsh sentence 33 years for armed
robbery that they always denied that
here but there is a feeling that those
two things became mixed up in many
people's minds and that's why he was
given such a long sentence it was
mentioned briefly in the hearing today
that the commissioners saying they
received a lot of letters from members
of the public for and against granting
him parole and saying that a lot of
those against were about writing letters
about his acquittal in 1995 but the
commissioner said today that wouldn't be
considered as part of this as it
shouldn't be this is about that armed
robbery conviction but huge interest and
the the the series of documentaries and
a dramatization of his life that have
been aired in the US and around the
world recently have ramped up that
interest again a lot of people have
caused too young to remember what
happened in 1995 but OJ Simpson is very
much a cultural figure once again in the
US and that's why there's this level of
interest now and what's happened
and a strong believe here I've got a
strong belief here that he will it would
be a surprise if he wasn't granted
parole in the next half hour okay Greg
stay where this one would bring back in
Michael Mullen I mean hearing that I
mean that's Greg getting the feeling
they're on the I think in Carson City
and you did say that he was granted
parole by this board what four years ago
wasn't he laterally well because he was
sentenced to 12 offenses in 2008 and
some of them had a minimum parole its
minimum time served to five years and
they came up for parole four years ago
and others had the rest of them had a
minimum of nine because they were
consecutive they followed on from the
end of the first sentences so this is
why i'ma come here expecting to watch a
short hearing in which he would be
granted parole and I think Greg's right
I think the end of the day they'll still
say well he's a seventy year old man
he's done the time for a considerable
time for this sentence and we'll you
know we'll give him the benefit to doubt
they even had an officer in the captain
Cody to show about how he's going to
move to Florida and they and the
arrangements that we put in place for
drinking back and he breached his parole
but himself no favors at all his lawyer
didn't do many favors even calling the
witness bruce fremming at the end didn't
really do many favors why because OJ's
lawyer had described mr. freman as
probably an old an okay guy he's had
some hard times recently and he's
looking to he's looking for OJ to
satisfy a civil claim that he got it
succeed against OJ for money so you know
the temptation from seeing these old
friends and I was watching the faces of
the commissioners closely oh my god if I
was in a case like this you can you know
they just were not impressed by this at
all really weren't let's check back in
with Greg and in Kassel City there in
Nevada and Greg just talk us through
what sir
likely to happen I mean he not not not
with the decision but um they said
there'd be a short recess and they will
make a decision the parole board yeah I
remember they've had a lot of this
information that they'll be making their
judgment on before today they've had of
course his pre-sentence report
from the trial itself a parole report
about how he's behaved in in prison in
in that sense and so they have a lot of
the information aside from what they'll
be going on with with what he did or
didn't say in the in that
question-and-answer session they also
look at this risk assessment and there
are 11 questions on the risk assessment
and you get a point score for each one
points against you or some credits
things like your age at the time of your
first arrest well Oh Jay Simpsons first
arrest was for murder he was 46 at the
time so he gets say he doesn't he
doesn't score badly on that a history of
drug or alcohol similarly that that he
was he was been drinking at the time of
the offense so there are points there
but he's behaved well in prison he said
he had a good employment record leading
up to his time of going to prison he's
got a pension from the National Football
League still as a star player so the
feeling is he will score very well in
that risk assessment and that that
weighs in to to what they have to decide
but they said before this hearing they
believed it would be about 30 minutes
they are making a decision based largely
on on those factors that they would have
considered before but as we've been
hearing what he said and whether he
showed real remorse for those offenses
aside from saying sorry
they will be considering and that's what
Oh Jay Simpson will be waiting for and
we should say even if they grant parole
in the next few minutes it will be
October the 1st at the earliest that he
will walk free from Lovelock where he
was giving evidence from there will be a
lot of organization that has to go on
before he can but October the first the
earliest date that he could be free
okay well standby on that note Greg
Milan thanks very much indeed for the
time being that's in Nevada and we will
of course the clock is ticking then on
that half an hour that the parole board
gave us about 10 minutes of that has
gone so we're expecting a decision about
whether LJ Simpson will be granted
parole within the next what 2025 minutes
we'll have it all live for you on Sky
News before bats will have the
fundamental differences between Britain
and the EU as Brussels repeatedly called